[Applaudissements]
les femmes côté alors vous allez venir
avec moi n'allège pas ce qu'on va
accueillir tout de suite notre julien
combes et ses bas
[Applaudissements]
plaisir dis moi tu passes au sauna vers
21h alors julien alesi mettez-vous
lamont juju juge va se mettre là a lieu
juste avant niveau des jambes
vous avez quelques poils ouais vous avez
quand même quelques poils non vous
inquiétez pas monsieur suse ou vous
allez nous chanter le lac du connemara
de michel charasse et bien vous allez
devoir chanter et de l'est il ya nadège
qui est ici qui a été esthéticienne
voilà bonsoir nadège voilà alors nadège
vous avez vous et moi je ne sais pas ça
de la soumettre à ce niveau là et vous
allez devoir donc voilà vous savez faire
ou pas non je suis maladroit tu voulais
je le fasse c'est sûr j'ai déjà parlé
bien d'alger près par les biens dans le
micro pendant ce que je veux mais n'ont
aucun poids lourd alors alors julien
attention vous allez démarrer le lac du
connemara déjà attendez attendez
attendez déjà on va le préparer parce
que je vais déjà mettre les des trucs
attention son parti c'est rien c'est
rien ça voilà une chose du melhoun à
wissant parts au oui c'est pas de sa
faute simple est par contre oui c'est
ben oui alors attention jambes et les
genevez je vais mettre une deuxième
bande merci m tend la main depuis et
nadège est ce que voulaient m'aider oui
ben oui merci nadège a laissé ses sujets
ainsi julien et on va en mettre une
petite dernière
voilà c'est bien moi je comptais pitt
j'ai pu bien que julia donc vous
continuer à chanter les lacs du
connemara ensuite on aura nos amis et
les frérots de la vega pour qu'ils
feront un besoin cruel sur la tension là
et bien cela la salle alors voyez il
faut bien mettre ça comme ça oui
ah oui c'est bon au moins je pense que
ce soir je vais faire un petit tour du
côté du goût de me situer ça va vous
faire du bien attention juliao diva
c'est parti là bas
[Musique]
si long
ce mot
[Musique]
c'est tuer
ça se dorant ce
m oui mais au fond tout est lent
[Musique]
pour les
m'enfin
[Musique]
m
c'est
et encore
une corde
oui
merci gilles allard qui s'est passé
alors oui oui c'est mon point merci du
là je viens au beurre 10 pour le
brushing merci messieurs dames
[Applaudissements]